Ce soir, je voudrais vous parler de
cette préoccupation mondiale incroyable
qui est au croisement de l'utilisation des sols, de l'alimentation, et de l'environnement,
une chose dans laquelle nous nous reconnaissons tous,
et que j'appelle l'autre vérité qui dérange.
Mais d'abord, je voudrais vous faire voyager.
D'abord, visitons notre planète, mais de nuit,
et vue de l'espace.
Voilà à quoi ressemble notre planète vue de l'espace
la nuit, si vous deviez voyager à bord d'un satellite
autour de la planète. La première chose que vous remarqueriez,
bien entendu, c'est la prédominance de la présence humaine
sur notre planète.
Nous voyons des villes, nous voyons des champs pétrolifères,
on peut même distinguer les flottes de pêche au large,
on voit que nous dominons la majeure partie de notre planète,
et essentiellement via l'utilisation des énergies
qu'on voit ici de nuit.
Mais revenons en arrière, creusons un peu
et regardons notre planète de jour.
Ce qu'on voit de jour, ce sont les paysages.
Voici une région du bassin de l'Amazone, un endroit appelé Rondônia
dans le centre sud de l'Amazonie brésilienne.
Si vous faites vraiment attention, vous apercevrez
dans le coin supérieur droit une fine ligne blanche,
qui est une route construite dans les années 70.
Si nous revenons à cet endroit en 2001,
nous découvrirons que ces routes
débouchent sur plus de routes, et encore plus de routes plus loin,
au bout desquelles se trouve une petite clairière dans la forêt tropicale
où il y aura quelques vaches.
Ces vaches sont élevées pour leur viande. Nous mangerons ces vaches.
Ces vaches sont consommées principalement en Amérique du Sud,
au Brésil et en Argentine. Elles ne sont pas transportées jusqu'ici.
Mais ce schéma de déforestation en forme de squelette de poisson
est un phénomène qu'on remarque beaucoup autour des tropiques,
surtout dans cette région du monde.
Si on va un peu plus vers le Sud dans notre petit tour du monde,
on peut aller à la frontière bolivienne de l'Amazonie,
ici aussi en 1975, si vous faites vraiment attention,
vous verrez une fine ligne blanche traverser le canevas,
et une ferme isolée
au milieu de la jungle primitive.
Revenons une nouvelle fois quelques années plus tard, ici en 2003,
et nous verrons que ce paysage ressemble en fait
beaucoup plus à l'Iowa qu'à une forêt tropicale.
En réalité, ce que vous voyez ici ce sont des champs de soja.
Ce soja est transporté vers l'Europe et la Chine
pour nourrir les animaux, surtout après la frayeur causée par la maladie de la vache folle,
il y a environ 10 ans, qui fait qu'on ne veut plus donner à des animaux
des protéines animales, parce que ça transmet la maladie.
Au lieu de ça, nous voulons les nourrir avec plus de protéines végétales.
Donc le soja est en pleine expansion,
ce qui montre à quel point le commerce et la mondialisation
sont réellement responsables des liens entre les forêts tropicales
et l'Amazonie -- un monde incroyablement étrange
et interconnecté que nous avons aujourd'hui.
Bon, encore une fois, ce que nous constatons quand nous regardons
autour du monde pendant notre petit tour,
c'est que les paysages les uns après les autres
ont été vidés et modifiés pour faire pousser de la nourriture
et d'autres récoltes.
Une des questions que l'on a posées est :
quelle part de ce monde est utilisée pour faire pousser de la nourriture,
et où exactement, et comment peut-on changer ça
dans l'avenir, et qu'est-ce que cela signifie ?
Eh bien, notre équipe a étudié la question à une échelle mondiale,
en utilisant des données satellite et des données de terrain pour essayer de suivre
l'agriculture à une échelle mondiale.
Voilà ce que nous avons trouvé, et c'est effrayant.
Cette carte montre la présence d'agriculture
sur la planète Terre.
Les zones vertes sont les zones utilisées pour faire pousser des cultures,
comme le blé, le soja, le maïs ou le riz, etc.
C'est l'équivalent de 16 millions de km² de terres..
Si on rassemblait tout en un seul endroit,
ça ferait la taille de l'Amérique du Sud.
La seconde zone, en marron, représente les pâturages mondiaux
où les animaux vivent.
Ça représente environ 30 millions de km²,
ou environ la surface de l'Afrique,
une quantité monstrueuse de terres, ce sont les meilleures terres, bien entendu,
c'est ce que vous voyez. Et ce qui reste, est,
disons, le milieu du désert du Sahara, ou la Sibérie,
ou le milieu d'une forêt tropicale.
Nous utilisons déjà l'équivalent d'une planète.
Si on examine ça attentivement, on découvre que c'est environ 40%
de la surface des sols de la Terre qui sont consacrés à l'agriculture,
et c'est 60 fois plus grand
que toutes les zones dont nous nous plaignons,
les zones de banlieues et les villes dans lesquelles nous vivons essentiellement.
La moitié de l'humanité vit dans les villes de nos jours,
mais une zone 60 fois plus grande est consacrée à la culture d'aliments.
C'est un résultat étonnant,
et ça nous a vraiment choqués quand nous nous en sommes rendu compte.
Nous utilisons donc une énorme quantité de terres pour l'agriculture,
mais nous utilisons aussi énormément d'eau.
Voici une photographie de l'Arizona, prise d'avion,
et quand vous la regardez, votre réaction est
"Qu'est-ce qu'ils font pousser là-bas ?" En réalité,
ils font pousser des laitues au beau milieu du désert
en vaporisant de l'eau dessus.
L'ironie est qu'elles sont probablement vendues
dans nos supermarchés à Minneapolis et St Paul, nos Villes Jumelles.
Mais ce qui nous intéresse vraiment, c'est que cette eau doit venir
de quelque part, et elle vient d'ici,
du fleuve Colorado en Amérique du Nord.
Bon, le Colorado, un jour type dans les années 50,
n'était simplement ni en crue, ni en période de sécheresse,
un jour plutôt normal, il ressemblait à quelque chose comme ça.
Mais si nous revenons à nos jours, dans des conditions normales,
au même endroit exactement, voilà ce qu'il reste.
La différence est principalement qu'il sert à irriger le désert pour les cultures,
ou peut-être les terrains de golf à Scottsdale, comme vous voulez.
Ça représente beaucoup d'eau, et encore une fois, nous puisons de l'eau
et l'utilisons pour faire pousser des aliments,
et aujourd'hui, si vous allez vers l'aval du Colorado,
il s'assèche complètement et ne s'écoule plus dans l'océan.
Nous avons littéralement consommé une rivière entière d'Amérique du Nord
pour des besoins d'irrigation.
Mais ce n'est même pas le pire exemple au monde.
Le pire exemple est probablement la Mer d'Aral.
Beaucoup d'entre vous ont étudié ça en cours de géographie.
Elle se trouve dans l'ancienne Union Soviétique
entre le Kazakhstan et l'Ouzbekistan,
une des plus grandes mers intérieures du monde.
Mais il y a ici un paradoxe, parce que l'on dirait
qu'elle est entourée de déserts. Pourquoi donc y a-t-il une mer à cet endroit ?
La raison de sa présence ici est que sur la rive droite,
vous voyez 2 petites rivières qui descendent
au travers du sable, et alimentent le bassin en eau.
Ces rivières drainent la neige fondue qui vient des montagnes
très loin à l'Est, où la neige fond, et descend jusqu'à la rivière
en traversant le désert, ce qui forme la grande Mer d'Aral.
Eh bien, dans les années 50, les Soviétiques ont décidé de dévier cette eau
pour irriguer des plantations de coton dans le désert, croyez-le ou non,
au Kazakhstan, pour ensuite vendre le coton sur le marché international
et attirer les devises étrangères en Union Soviétique.
Ils avaient vraiment besoin d'argent.
Vous imaginez ce qui s'est passé. Vous coupez
l'arrivée d'eau de la Mer d'Aral, que va-t-il se passer ?
Ici nous sommes en 1973,
1986,
1999,
2004,
et il y a 11 mois environ.
C'est assez extraordinaire.
Une grande partie d'entre nous dans le public aujourd'hui vit dans le Midwest.
Imaginez si c'était le Lac Supérieur.
Imaginez si c'était le Lac Huron.
C'est un changement incroyable.
Ce n'est pas seulement un changement par rapport à l'eau
et à son niveau, c'est un changement dans les fondamentaux
de l'environnement de cette région.
Commençons par ceci.
L'Union Soviétique n'avait pas vraiment de Sierra Club.
Disons-le de cette manière.
Ce que vous trouvez au fond de la Mer d'Aral n'est pas joli.
Il y a beaucoup de déchets toxiques, beaucoup de choses
qui ont été jetées là et qui sont maintenant en suspension dans l'air.
Une de ces petites îles qui était isolée
et impossible à rejoindre était un lieu
de test des armes biologiques soviétiques.
Vous pouvez y aller à pied aujourd'hui.
Les modèles météorologiques ont changé.
19 des 20 espèces uniques de poissons que l'on trouvait uniquement
dans la Mer d'Aral ont désormais disparu de la surface de la Terre.
C'est un véritable désastre environnemental.
Mais revenons chez nous.
Voici une photo qu'Al Gore m'a donnée il y a quelques années
qu'il a prise quand il était en URSS
il y a très très longtemps,
et qui montre les flottes de pêche dans la Mer d'Aral.
Vous voyez le canal qu'ils creusent ?
Ils voulaient tellement faire flotter les bateaux
dans ce qu'il restait d'eau, mais ils ont finalement dû abandonner
parce que les piles d'amarrage ne correspondaient jamais
avec les rives qui reculaient.
Je ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez, mais je suis terrifié à l'idée que les futurs
archéologues creuseront là et écriront des histoires sur
notre époque dans l'Histoire et se demanderont, "Mais à quoi pensiez-vous ?"
C'est pourtant ce qui nous attend.
Nous utilisons déjà environ 50% de l'eau douce sur Terre
qui est durable, et l'agriculture à elle seule
utilise 70% de cette quantité.
Nous utilisons donc beaucoup d'eau, beaucoup de terres pour l'agriculture.
Nous utilisons aussi beaucoup de l'atmosphère pour l'agriculture.
Généralement quand nous pensons à l'atmosphère,
nous pensons au changement climatique et aux gaz à effet de serre,
et surtout à tout ce qui tourne autour de l'énergie,
mais il se trouve que l'agriculture est l'un des plus gros producteurs
de gaz à effet de serre.
Si vous regardez le dioxyde de carbone qui provient
des forêt tropicales qu'on brûle,
ou au méthane qui provient des vaches et du riz,
ou aux oxydes nitreux qui proviennent de l'usage excessif d'engrais,
il s'avère que l'agriculture représente 30% des gaz à effet de serre
produits par l'activité humaine et qui vont dans l'atmosphère.
C'est plus que ce que produisent les moyens de transport.
C'est plus que ce que produit l'électricité.
C'est plus que ce produisent toutes les autres industries, en fait.
A elle seule, c'est le plus grand émetteur de gaz à effet de serre
parmi toutes les activités humaines au monde.
Et pourtant, nous n'en parlons pas beaucoup.
Nous avons cette incroyable prééminence de l'agriculture aujourd'hui
qui domine notre planète,
que ce soit 40% de la surface de nos terres,
70% de l'eau que nous utilisons,
30% de l'émission des gaz à effet de serre.
Nous avons doublé les flux d'azote et de phosphore
dans le monde rien qu'en utilisant des engrais,
ce qui entraîne d'énormes problèmes de qualité de l'eau des rivières,
des lacs, et même des océans ; et c'est aussi le plus grand
moteur de destruction de la biodiversité.
Sans l'ombre d'un doute, l'agriculture est
l'unique plus grande puissance déchaînée sur cette planète
depuis la fin de l'ère glacière. Aucun doute là-dessus.
Elle est aussi importante que le changement climatique.
Et tout cela se passe au même moment.
Mais ce dont il faut vraiment se rappeler, c'est
que tout n'est pas négatif. Je ne dis pas que l'agriculture est une mauvaise chose.
En fait, nous en sommes complètement dépendants.
Ce n'est pas une option. Ce n'est pas un luxe. C'est une nécessité absolue.
Nous devons produire de la nourriture et nourrir,
produire des textiles et même des biocarburants pour quelque 7 milliards de personnes
dans le monde aujourd'hui, et nous allons voir plutôt
une augmentation de la demande concernant l'agriculture
dans l'avenir. Elle ne disparaîtra pas.
Elle va même grossir, principalement à cause de
l'augmentation de la population. Nous sommes 7 milliards aujourd'hui
probablement au moins 9 demain,
et 9 et demi avant de disparaitre.
Plus important, le changement de régimes.
Alors que le monde s'enrichit et que sa population s'accroit,
on constate des augmentations dans la consommation de viande,
ce qui nécessite beaucoup plus de ressources qu'un régime végétarien.
Résumons : plus de gens, qui mangeant plus, et plus riche,
et évidemment, une crise de l'énergie qui survient au même moment,
quand on doit remplacer le pétrole par d'autres sources d'énergie
qui devront au final intégrer des biocarburants sous une forme ou une autre
et des sources de bio-énergie.
Vous combinez tout ça. Il est vraiment difficile de voir
comment nous allons pouvoir finir ce siècle
sans au moins doubler la production mondiale agricole.
Comment allons-nous faire ? Comment allons-nous
réussir à doublier la production agricole dans le monde ?
Eh bien, nous pourrions essayer de cultiver plus de terres.
Voici une analyse que nous avons réalisée : sur la gauche vous voyez
où sont les cultures aujourd'hui, et sur la droite, où elles pourraient être en nous basant sur
la composition des sols, du climat, en partant du principe que le changement climatique
ne modifie pas trop tout ça,
ce qui n'est pas une hypothèse correcte.
On pourrait cultiver plus de terres, mais le problème
est que les terres restantes sont des zones sensibles.
Elles ont une grande biodiversité, beaucoup de carbone,
des choses que nous voulons protéger.
On pourrait alors obtenir plus de nourriture en étendant les zones cultivées,
mais il ne vaudrait mieux pas,
parce que c'est une chose très, très dangereuse sur le plan écologique.
En revanche, on pourrait geler les effets
de l'agriculture et mieux cultiver les terres dont nous disposons.
Voilà le travail que nous faisons pour essayer de mettre en évidence les endroits
dans le monde où on pourrait améliorer le rendement
sans nuire à l'environnement.
Les zones vertes ici montrent où les rendements de maïs,
le maïs étant juste un exemple,
sont déjà élevés, probablement au maximum de ce qu'on peut
trouver sur Terre de nos jours avec ce climat et ces sols,
mais les zones marrons et jaunes sont des endroits où
on ne récolte peut-être que 20 ou 30% du rendement
qu'on pourrait espérer obtenir.
Vous voyez beaucoup de ces zones en Afrique, même en Amérique latine,
mais, et c'est intéressant, en Europe de l'Est, où étaient
l'URSS et les membres du Bloc de l'Est,
au niveau agricole, rien n'est fait.
Mais cela nécessiterait l'utilisation de nutriments et d'eau.
Cela sera bio, traditionnel
ou un mélange des deux.
Les plantes ont besoin d'eau et de nutriments.
Mais nous pouvons y arriver, il existe des opportunités pour que ça fonctionne.
Mais nous devons le faire d'une manière censée
pour répondre aux besoins alimentaires de base pour l'avenir
et aux besoins environnementaux de base pour l'avenir
Nous devons trouver le compromis entre
cultiver la nourriture et avoir un environnement sain.
En ce moment, c'est plutôt "tout ou rien".
On peut faire pousser des aliments en arrière-plan --
voyez ici un champ de soja --
dans ce diagramme en fleur, vous voyez que nous faisons pousser beaucoup de nourriture,
mais nous n'avons pas beaucoup d'eau potable, nous ne stockons pas
beaucoup de carbone, nous n'avons pas beaucoup de biodiversité.
Au premier plan, nous avons cette prairie
qui est merveilleuse du point de vue environnemental,
mais vous ne pouvez rien en tirer. Qu'y a-t-il à manger là ?
Nous devons trouver un moyen de cumuler les deux fonctions,
dans un nouveau genre d'agriculture qui les réunirait.
Quand je parle de tout ça, les gens me disent souvent :
"Eh bien, doit-on choisir ?" -- nourriture bio,
aliments locaux, OGMs, produits de substitution, lois sur l'agriculture --
et oui, il y a là beaucoup de bonnes idées,
mais aucune d'entre elles n'est un remède miracle.
En réalité, je pense que c'est surtout un tir groupé
J'adore le principe du tir groupé. Si vous en combinez les effets,
vous obtenez quelque chose de vraiment puissant,
mais vous devez les combiner.
Ce qu'il nous reste à faire, je pense, c'est inventer un nouveau genre
d'agriculture qui mixe les meilleures idées
de l'agriculture commerciale et de la révolution écologique
avec les meilleures idées de la culture bio et locale
et les meilleures idées de la protection de l'environnement,
afin qu'elles ne s'opposent pas,
mais qu'elles collaborent pour former une nouvelle agriculture,
quelque chose que j'appelle la "terraculture", ou l'agriculture pour toute une planète.
Cette discussion a été très difficile,
et nous faisosn le maximum pour présenter ces points-clefs
aux gens pour limiter la controverse,
et augmenter la collaboration.
Je veux vous montrer une courte vidéo qui présente
les efforts que nous faisons en ce moment même pour rapprocher ces deux partis
autour d'une même discussion. Laissez-moi vous le montrer.
(Musique)
("Institut de l'Environnement, Université du Minnesota : Vers la Découverte")
("La population mondiale augmente
de 75 millions de personnes chaque année.
Cela représente presque la taille de l'Allemagne.
Aujourd'hui, nous approchons des 7 milliards de personnes.
A ce rythme, nous atteindrons les 9 milliards d'ici 2040.
Nous avons tous besoin de nourriture.
Mais comment faire ?
Comment allons-nous nourrir un monde en expansion sans détruire notre planète ?
Nous savons déjà que le changement climatique est un gros problème.
Mais ce n'est pas le seul.
Nous devons faire face à "l'autre vérité qui dérange."
Une crise agricole mondiale.
Augmentation de la population + consommation de viande + consommation de produits laitiers + coûts de l'énergie + production de bioénergie = tensions sur les ressources naturelles.
Plus de 40% des terres de la planète ont été défrichées pour l'agriculture.
Les terres cultivées recouvrent 16 millions de km² dans le monde.
C'est presque la taille de l'Amérique latine.
Les pâturages couvrent 30 millions de km² dans le monde.
C'est la taille de l'Afrique.
L'agriculture utilise 60 fois plus de terres que les zones urbaines et suburbaines combinées.
L'irrigation est le plus gros utilisateur d'eau sur Terre.
Nous utilisons 2 800 km cubes d'eau pour des récoltes chaque année.
C'est assez pour remplir 7305 fois l'Empire State Building chaque jour.
Aujourd'hui, de nombreux fleuves ont un débit réduit.
Certains s'assèchent tout simplement.
Regardez la Mer d'Aral, devenue un désert.
Ou le Colorado, qui ne se déverse plus dans l'océan.
Les engrais ont plus que doublé la quantité de phosphore et d'azote dans l'environnement.
Quelles sont les conséquences ?
Une pollution de l'eau à grande échelle
et une dégradation massive des lacs et des rivières.
C'est surprenant, mais l'agriculture est ce qui contribue le plus au changement climatique.
Elle génère 30% des émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
C'est plus que les émissions provenant de l'électricité ou de l'industrie,
ou des avions, des trains et des voitures du monde entier.
La plupart des émissions agricoles viennent de la déforestation tropicale,
du méthane des animaux et des champs de riz,
et les oxydes nitreux liés à l'usage intensif d'engrais.
Rien de ce que nous faisons ne transforme plus le monde que l'agriculture.
Rien de ce que nous faisons n'est plus crucial pour notre survie.
Voilà le dilemme...
Alors que le monde grossit de plusieurs milliards de gens,
nous allons devoir doubler, peut-être même tripler, la production mondiale de nourriture.
Que faisons-nous à partir de ce constat ?
Nous avons besoin d'une plus grande conversation, d'un dialogue international.
Nous devons investir dans de vraies solutions ;
des mesures incitatives pour les agriculteurs, de l'agriculture de précision, de nouvelles variétés de cultures, l'irrigation au goutte à goutte,
le recyclage des eaux usées, de meilleures façons de labourer, des régimes plus intelligents.
Nous avons besoin que tout le monde se mette autour de cette table.
Les représentants de l'agriculture commerciale,
de la préservation de l'environnement,
et de l'agriculture bio...
doivent travailler main dans la main.
Il n'existe pas de solution unique.
Nous devons collaborer,
imaginer,
rester déterminés,
parce que nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre d'échouer.
Comment allons-nous nourrir le monde sans le détruire ?"
Nous somme confrontés aujourd'hui à l'un des plus grands défis
de toute l'histoire de l'Humanité :
le besoin de nourrir 9 milliards de personnes
et ce, de manière durable, équitable et juste,
et en protégeant en même temps notre planète
pour cette génération et les suivantes.
Ce sera une des choses les plus difficiles
que nous ayons faites dans l'histoire de l'Humanité,
nous devons absolument le faire correctement,
et dès le premier et unique essai.
Merci beaucoup. (Applaudissements)